[Director] Tell me a
little bit about The Hajj.
Can I get a sip of my water first?
[Director] Of course, yeah.
Because this is such a tall tale.
(Director laughs)
Hajj is, it's a pilgrimage
to Mecca, Saudi Arabia,
and it's a requirement to
do once in your lifetime.
My mother invited me, and I was
at a kind of low point in my life.
I was getting cast in Hollywood
and playing the terrorist,
so I was perpetuating and
feeding the stereotype.
And then, the day before
I was leaving for Hajj,
I got a bunch of calls for auditions.
And I called my mom and I
was like, "Oh I can't leave,"
"Hollywood's knocking on my door."
And she said, "You know why
you're going to Hajj, right?"
And I said, "Yeah, you invited me."
And she's like, "No, God invited you."
"You can only come by
invitation from God."
So now I'm like, "What do I say to God?"
(laughs) When I get there, you know.
"Sorry I haven't been in touch."
"My phone was on vibrate."
It just kinda spooked me, you know?
When we arrived at the main mosque,
I remember it looking like
the religious Las Vegas.
We were driving through
the mountains at night,
they kind of opened up,
and there was this glimmering spectacle
of lights and pulsating energy.
We pulled on this balcony
overlooking the Kaaba,
which is the black box building
right in the heart of Mecca,
where Prophet Muhammad
threw out all the statues
and claimed that there's one God.
And there's millions of pilgrims,
some coming in on first-class flights,
others are walking their camels
through the desert with
cracked, bloody feet.
The high of the high
and the low of the low
and then everything in between.
And everyone's dressed in white.
And I remember looking over at my mother,
and she was on her knees crying.
And so of course, you
know, that made me cry,
so I buckled and I started crying.
And it was just this
magnificent feeling and force
of something so much bigger than you.
Epic, out of a movie.
It's futuristic.
They say in Islam that
Hajj is a small version
of what the Day of Judgment is going
to look like and feel like.
So it's like a dress rehearsal.
You are supposed to go to
Hajj when you have sinned
all that you are supposed to sin,
and in order to clean your sins
and kinda push the restart button.
I went at a time when, you
know, I was 27 years old.
I'm 42 now so, you know,
I gotta go back. (laughs)